but what was it like the first time you
went to a convention because when you
went to a convention it was probably
what was i mean i i can imagine you went
for other roles but
this had to be the biggest no you didn't
so you hadn't been to a convention
and so the first time they say michael
cudlitz what was your response because i
guarantee there was 400 people in line
the first time they well maybe let's
back up even the first
convention ever i was at was new york
comic-con when my character was
introduced
four thousand people in the was it javid
chavis javascript jacob javid center
jacob javits javits
yeah and uh i say four thousand i think
that's a little bit under but
it's like whatever that meant the main
room holds it's more than four thousand
but
i don't know the exact number i know
it's not the six
almost seven thousand that's in san
diego um
they start talking about
we're gonna do a gag i'm basically going
to go out there dressed as
uh just some cosplayer i got a like a
cheap plastic cowboy hat and a
sport jacket and a a
white uh what's the
what's the face the white face with the
mustache
uh oh the uh v for vendetta no what is
it yes
yes something similar to that or maybe
it's even more just innocuous
right anyway so i'm up there and
i have a microphone and they want me to
basically do this
iconic uh chunk of dialogue from the
from the uh from the graphic novel and
the the microphone is right next to me
where everybody can ask group questions
so when they say okay everybody come on
up to ask questions
i'm like right there and i just stand up
so i'm hiding with the microphone and
the thing and they're getting
they're talking about the show and
they're this and that blah blah blah and
they go on and i don't know i open up
the questions
and i stand up and uh i stand up
in front of the person they're like hey
what are you doing and i turn around i'm
like shut up
and they're like what and i talk like
hey
i'm like give and start giving him
i'm like where's abraham
these people want to see where abraham
is you write the show right and robert
kirk was like look
i'm at some point i'm like you know what
shut up
give me an answer like i'm really
confrontational at this point i find out
later
on that andrew lincoln's wife was there
and she was like oh my god there's a
crazy man who's
gonna pull out a gun and open fire and
like it's gonna be some crazy shut up
so yvette was
monitoring hard work wasn't monitoring
that time
uh and she's like i'm sorry i can't hear
you because of your mask
and you know you take your mask off i
was like sure
so i take off drop the helmet pull off
the thing drop the jacket
and i'm standing there dressed as
abraham
and the audience because you
know the people who go to the
conventions that's one breed of fan but
the fans said go to the conventions and
then wait in line for nine hours for the
panel
whole other level love them they know
love them they're committed
exactly what's going down they
nuts and i thought that was over and i
was like
holy crap this is insane and event's
like you know why don't you come on up
here and just and say hi to everybody
i'm walking up and i remember this is a
thing online everyone can check it out
there's a photo of me at new york comic
con
i get the year uh i've been walking
across stage and i walk up and i i
hold up a fist uh or hold up to go to
wave
and uh because they're all cheering
everyone's cheering and the minute i put
my hand up you know i'm thinking holy
crap this is insane i put my hand up
and the wall of sound that hit me
well i was literally speechless
i was literally holy what the hell
that's a beautiful thing